J'adorais Maléfique quand j'étais
petite, c'était mon personnage préféré de Disney
, alors quand j'ai entendu dire qu'il
pourrait y avoir un film Maléfique car nous sommes
excités, le personnage de Maléfique
est vraiment fantastique et nous avons Angelina
Jolie donc ma tâche était de vivre  jusqu'à
eux deux j'ai été vraiment ému par le
scénario c'était comme découvrir ce grand
mystère
Angelina Jolie est parfaite pour le rôle
c'est le mariage parfait de l'actrice et du
rôle à mon avis depuis longtemps c'est un
de ces personnages que pour moi
tu pourrais  je n'ai pas à le faire hé quittez ma
vérité rapide maintenant traitez une pseudo seule
chose je suis un père le verre a fait tout ce
qu'ils ont fait un circuit à deux pour toute son
entreprise elle est si élégante
qu'elle a en quelque sorte cette beauté intense dont elle
a un mauvais sens  amusant,
attention à ce qui n'est qu'un groupe, ce n'est pas
une astrologie